i didn't realize that it's five times
you've hosted saturday night live
yeah you like doing that right i love it
that's fun it's great
is it um the type of thing where you
walk in to a writer's meeting and like
they know you as an actress but do you
ever say hey listen i can do some
characters i do some voices i do this do
you pitch them on on specific things or
do they just write everything and and
and that's it um well in you know the
first couple of times i think you know
they probably had no idea what to expect
and neither did i it was it's such a and
i mean i'm sure that you've been
backstage in a part of the seen a bit of
how it works and everything but it's
it's uh you know it's a well-oiled
machine it can be a little bit
intimidating going into those writers
meetings and and you know i mean for
them you're just you know you're they're
the host that week but they've been you
know there'll be another host the next
week you know it's a it's a crazy
environment it's an amazing environment
do you memorize your lines or do you
work off too fast better to work off the
cue cards why because they say it just
kind of screws things because
everybody's looking at uh right exactly
because it actually has to do with where
your look which camera you're looking
into when you do when you give your
delivery and so it's better to use the
cue cards although
uh uh the recently the uh uh member of
the cast told me that uh when they had
betty white hosting she couldn't read
the cue card so she memorized all of her
lines and she was just she was totally
pitch perfect yeah and we're perfect she
had everything she's just a pro that is
amazing unbelievable yeah she's
something she's incredible